what if we told y'all that once a month
past the human racism pain and the other
half don't want to hear [ __ ] about it
see Rachel stone welcome to restoration
orientation oh no you know now we know
you don't want to hear about it but they
don't want to have it so sit your ass
down and listen for once in your life
today we will talk to all you man about
what happens to your women when they are
on their periods and why it's important
to be sensitive to that shared don't say
chillax relax calm down and alcohol
don't say ass fat grumpy or cranky
cranky they got blood coming out of
their vaginas you're some biblical
plague [ __ ] y'all that would be like
once a month if you had locusts flying
how do you dig for a week your ass
wouldn't be cranky your ass to be like
Oh
Oh [ __ ] when they bleeding
if you ain't getting and everytime they
pee it's like a shining in the toilet be
supportive be empathetic but whatever
you do do not try to solve it don't even
bring that [ __ ] up when women be hanging
out together their periods will sink
vaginas be communicating they got their
own vagina language talking about if you
find yourself around a group of women
and they all have a backache back away
slowly what's that in your pocket there
shaboots recognize this right a space
dynamite dancer pteropod learn what your
[ __ ] has to go through first you put
this piece in then you push this part
then you throw this part away do that
several times a day for a week every
goddamn month that's the worst thing
ever
all the tires much worse for them than
it is for you to hear about it
appearance is important that's how the
body gets rid of the old egg so we can
cook up them new ones so listen to
what's going on with your female
emotionally and get your [ __ ] some
chocolate don't call her a [ __ ] but
[Applause]
you
you